hello and welcome to the episode the
fortune teller um as the episodes go in
general so cute that's about all I can
really say about it it's a cute little
episode um you know maybe borderline
filler but at the same time it's sort of
I was guessing continuing but more kind
of really get started the relationship
between Aang and Katara you know sort of
the quasi romance they have going on um
but there's a few other things on top of
that I think it has some interesting
messages about you know fate fate and
faith in and what you put uh you know
the most stock in and destiny and how
much you you make for yourself and how
much is just life and blah blah blah so
the story of this one is they find this
town that's where everything in this
town is are run by this fortune-teller
in a sense you know she doesn't rule the
town but she can apparently see the
future and predict it and everybody
really enjoys that and you know because
they know what's gonna happen
um and she can do it by you know doing
sort of the typical fortune things you
know whatever looking at the cracks and
Bo and Jo looking at the clouds or you
know a bunch of new agey stuff um and
and Sokka particularly does not like
this because he's very much you know you
should be able to determine your own
destiny you know you shouldn't put your
faith in someone that's saying this is
gonna happen and you just sort of make
it happen because we're told it was
gonna happen you know you hear the stuff
like in the matrix and stuff like that
you know fun things like that um and one
of the things is that she says you know
the volcano is now can't destroy the
village they're right next to a volcano
and the volcano starts to erupt so uh
aang and sokka determined well okay this
must be what she must be wrong about
this so we have to change it so they
very cleverly I like how Aang and Katara
they used the airbending and the
waterbending to manipulate the clouds to
make the fortune-teller see something
else that's very smart yeah like you
know using what you have a you know in
different ways so that's
clever um unfortunate teller sees it
says oh no it says death we have to do
something about it so now everyone will
listen and you know try their best to
avoid the volcano or do something about
it because before there's a know but the
fortune-teller said the volcano won't
hurt us at all you know we don't have to
do anything so I was until they changed
it they decided to do it to change stuff
and they create this little path and the
lava comes through and doesn't hurt the
town so the fortune teller was still
right but at the same time they did have
to do something about it so that's a
good mix I like that I think it's a good
message to get out to people you know
and kids and stuff um the the other
thing they're sort of building up is
that you know like I said there's this
kind of romance you could obviously see
blooming between between Katara and Aang
and here is she's finally waking up to
it you know because the fortune teller
essentially says you know it's gonna be
a great bender that you fall in love
with and suddenly she puts it together
hey eggs a great bender like at the end
of the episode because um there's
something I don't romances are tough to
do that they're tough to do effectively
and this is one of the reasons why
because there's always someone's in love
with the other one but the other either
is not or doesn't see it and for a few
times that's cute but it gets done so
much and it bothers me what's always
like you know this destiny thing will
open your eyes to it or something like
that or you know it's why can't they
just sort of realise it what why do they
have to be told no you're in love with
this person you know well why can't they
just feel why can't they let it just
evolve naturally um so maybe they're
gonna do that more in the series but I
don't know that that's just sort of a me
thing I like it
romances are usually not done the best
in many forms of medium I bet they're
either way too glanced over or they're
way to simplify um you know and
it's like love in many respects is
simplified but in different ways in
varying ways not just this one you know
you have to be told or someone's in love
and the other isn't that circumstances
point in the other direction or you know
something that lasts through a show you
know I don't know it's tough to do in
shows that that's the place I so rarely
see it done right is on TV shows and you
think that'd be the place where they
could do it the best because you have
time to really grow a relationship but
instead they just tease you the
whole time and attend your will they or
won't they when you know they are most
likely will 9 out of 10 they will uh but
who knows maybe they lean towards an
hour pant maybe she'll find another a
great vendor and that's gonna be the
person then she's conflicted and who
does she go with like I don't know it
could be May they're building that up
but um I don't know it's that that's not
fun to me I like uh I like real you know
I like really looking into however
lationship is gonna bloom Eve if it's
with kids you know I think in fact is
even more interesting if you do it with
kids so I I don't think they need to
rely on that but uh the only thing I'll
say about this episode there's like this
one character this little girl I had
like this big gap in her teeth is just
adorable in this show this is
like the cutest kid in this show and she
has a crush on a and constantly trying
to get his attention while he's
constantly trying to get Katara's
attentions you know Serpa not really a
love triangle because it doesn't come
back but you know what I mean um so yeah
I just that character really stood out I
thought was a very uh yeah a very cute
very funny
um aside from that yeah not too much
else on this one like I said just sort
of a very straightforward a basic
episode just again you know once a while
we need a break from the fire nation and
the chase um you know so I never want
those people it's like come on get back
to the story all the time it's like no I
we need these I totally now do we need
these cuz if you do keep coming back to
the chase the whole time you're just
gonna get tired of the chase you're
gonna get tired of him always getting
away or getting capture and then getting
away so you know you need these
variations so I told get and it's a cute
little episode so um
yeah that's all I can say about that one
later